fages gardien ils sont plus de 500
immigrants à la recherche d'emploi comme
tarik laabidi ingénieur mécanique de
formation originaire du maroc arrivé à
montréal depuis trois mois j'ai une
expérience de cette année dans le
domaine industriel géré occuper pas mal
de postes dont des multinationales
américaines et françaises au maroc
certains moins qualifiés comme cette
réfugiée syrienne ali occupent eliane au
pays depuis deux ans elle cherche un
emploi dans le service à la clientèle
je parle maintenant français je parlais
pas du taux de tout eh ben c'est sûr est
vrai pourquoi que jose maintenant de
temps à venir tout faire l'entretien
la formule est simple des rencontres
éclair c'est à 10 minutes entre les
représentants d'entreprises et des
chercheurs d'emploi organisé par la
maisonnée un organisme qui vient en aide
aux migrants dans le contexte économique
actuel l'exercice est nécessaire
les gens ont besoin de savoir où on peut
aller chercher cette main-d'oeuvre
immigrante et nous on est la porte
d'entrée pour la main-d'oeuvre migrante
donc on est on fait le lien pour la
vingtaine d'entreprises participantes
les besoins sont énormes et tout aussi
varié on a des besoins dans tous les
secteurs d'activité donc si on regarde
les emplois généraux on va parler de
préposés aux services alimentaires
préposés de jeunes salubrité il offre de
passer tellement et non présentement il
faut faisait marquer puis pour se
démarquer en fait faut être présent sur
le terrain
mais le plus grand défi demeure encore
la reconnaissance du diplôme
souvent je vois qu'ils ont les critères
de base sont en mesure de faire le
travail mais j'ai absolument besoin de
ce document là c'est comme une preuve
comme quoi y ont leur diplôme
l'an dernier 30 % des participants ont
réussi à décrocher une seconde entrevue
ça s'était très bien passé si tarik ne
repart pas avec un emploi immédiatement
l'essentiel est accompli un premier
contact avec le marché de l'emploi au
québec
et si jacques houde rue charbonneau raid
au canada montréal